>> Tucker: FOR WELL MORE THAN
A CENTURY, PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY HAVE MADE THE CASE FOR
SOCIALISM BUT THAT SEED HAS
NEVER REALLY SPROUTED AND TAKEN
ROOT BUT THAT'S CHANGING.
YOUNG AMERICANS APPEAR TO BE,
EVERY POLL SHOWS, SOURING ON OUR
ECONOMIC SYSTEM, CAPITALISM.
ILHAN OMAR AND THE DISPUTE 11
SET THE AGENDA.
YOU CAN SEE IT EVERY DAY.
HE IS ONE EXAMPLE.
ON ABC RECENTLY,
SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS BLASTED
HIS RIVAL LIST ELIZABETH WARREN
WITH THE WORST INSULT HE COULD
THINK
OF.
>> THERE ARE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
ELIZABETH AND MYSELF.
ELIZABETH IS A CAPITALIST.
I'M NOT.
AND THE REASON I AM NOT IS
BECAUSE I WILL NOT TOLERATE FOR
ONE SECOND THE KIND OF GREED AND
CORRUPTION AND INCOME AND WEALTH
AND INEQUALITY AND SO MUCH
SUFFERING THAT IS GOING ON IN
THIS COUNTRY TODAY WHICH IS
UNNECESSARY.
>> Tucker: AND OTHER
DIFFERENCES, HE MIGHT BE
ACTUALLY EVEN MORE
SELF-IMPORTANT THAN SHE HAS.
WE WILL LET YOU DECIDE.
IN ANY CASE, AND 2019, THAT'S A
REAL ATTACK ON THE LEFT.
MY OPPONENT IS A CAPITALIST!
WHATEVER THEY CHOOSE TO CALL IT,
THE DEMOCRATIC BASE IS DEMANDING
SOCIALIST POLICIES AND
INCREASINGLY, THE CANDIDATES ARE
HAPPY TO OBLIGE.
>> WILL TELL YOU WHAT I BELIEVE
IN TERMS OF DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISM.
I AGREE WITH WHAT GOES ON IN
CANADA AND IN SCANDINAVIA,
GUARANTEEING HEALTH CARE TO ALL
PEOPLE AS A HUMAN RIGHT.
>> I THINK UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE
NEED TO HAVE A MEANS BY WHICH
THEY ARE COVERED WHEN THEY'RE
SICK.
>> RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOUR
GOVERNMENT PLAN WOULDN'T PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: SOCIALISM WITH OPEN
BORDERS!
THAT'S THE TREND.
SENATOR RAND PAUL OF KENTUCKY IS
FIGHTING IT.
HE HAS A BRAND-NEW BOOK OUT
CALLED A CASE AGAINST SOCIALISM.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
SENATOR, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
CONGRATS ON THE BOOK BY THE WAY.
I THINK YOUR BOOK TO HER IS
PROBABLY A VERY INTERESTING
WINDOW WITH WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW.
MY DEEPER QUESTION IS, WHY ARE
WE THERE?
MOST ECONOMIC INDICATORS SEEM
POSITIVE READ WHY ARE WE
EMBRACING SOCIALISM?
>> WHEN I WAS AGAIN, WE WOULD
SAY WILL THAT LIBERAL IS
PROBABLY SOCIALIST BUT THEY
WOULD NEVER ADMIT TO IT.
I HOPE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
ARE RUNNING ON THE LABEL OF
BEING A DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST.
I THINK SOME OF THE DAYS THAT
THEY HAVE FORGOTTEN THEIR
HISTORY.
AND PART OF THE BOOK WE TALK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT HITLER WAS A
SOCIALIST, STALIN WAS A
SOCIALIST, AND ABOUT 100 MILLION
PEOPLE DIED IN THE LAST CENTURY
PRIMARILY FROM AND FAMINE AND
PRIMARILY FROM THE COLLECTIVISM
AND SOCIALISM, BUT THEY SEEM TO
HAVE FORGOTTEN IT.
THEN I WENT TO THE FACT THAT
THEY'LL SAY WELL, WE WERE FOR
CASTRO BUT NOT SO MUCH FOR JOBS
IS BUT WHAT WE ARE REALLY FOR A
SCANDINAVIAN SOCIALISM.
SO WE SPENT A LOT OF THE BOOK
DESCRIBING THE FACT THAT
SCANDINAVIA FIRST IS NOT
SOCIALIST, BUT WE ALSO REPORT
THAT BERNIE IS ACTUALLY TOO MUCH
OF A SOCIALIST TO EVEN GET
ELECTED IN DENMARK.
THE PRIME MINISTER OF DENMARK
SAID BERNIE, QUIT CALLING A
SOCIALIST, WE ARE NOT SOCIALIST,
WE ARE OPEN FOR BUSINESS, AND
YOU ARE RUINING OUR BUSINESS BY
TELLING THE WORLD WE ARE
SOCIALIST WHEN WERE NOT.
>> Tucker: THE SOCIALISM OF
NORWAY IS BASED ON OIL DEPOSITS.
SO WHAT'S INTERESTING THOUGH IS
THAT CONSERVATIVES OFTEN SAY
SOCIALISM MAKES PEOPLE MORE POOR
BUT THE PEOPLE WHO RUN SOCIALIST
SYSTEMS ALWAYS WIND UP VERY
RICH, I'VE NOTICED.
>> WE MAKE THAT POINT IN A BOOK
THAT THERE'S ALWAYS THE TOP 1%.
IN OUR COUNTRY, IT'S LARGELY
BASED ON MERIT, AND SOCIALISM,
IT'S LARGELY LARGELY BASED ON
WHO YOU KNOW.
WHETHER YOU ARE WEALTHY, CAN
HAVE PLENTY TO EAT, FOR EXAMPLE,
IN VENEZUELA, THE AVERAGE PERSON
IS LOST 20 POUNDS OVER THE LAST
YEAR.
MAJURO HAS GAINED ABOUT
50 POUNDS IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS.
SO MAJURO IS GETTING BIGGER AND
BIGGER.
HE CAN EVEN FIT INTO HIS
CLOTHES.
HE SO FAT, HIS GENERALS ARE FAT,
THEY ARE ALL WELL THOUGHT, BUT
THE AVERAGE PERSON HAS LOST
20 POUNDS.
THAT'S A STATEMENT OF WHAT THE
AVERAGE LIFE IS LIKE FOR SOMEONE
AND SOCIALISM.
>> Tucker: SO IF INEQUALITY
BECOMES SO PROFOUND IT CAUSES
INSTABILITY IN YOUR SOCIETY, BUT
SOCIALISM IS NOT THE CURE FOR
THAT.
>> RIGHT.
AND ACTUALLY LOOK AT INEQUALITY
ALSO AND IT FINDS THAT THE
STUDIES ARE TRUE.
IF YOU LOOK AT INCOME INEQUALITY
IN DEVELOPED NATIONS, INCOME
INEQUALITY IS ACTUALLY
PROMOTIONAL TO ECONOMIC GROWTH.
IT DOESN'T SLOW DOWN ECONOMIC
GROWTH AT ALL, AND REALLY WHAT
WE SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT, IN
WHICH SOCIETY WOULD YOU RATHER
LIVE IN?
WHERE THE AVERAGE PERSON MAKES
$30,000 A YEAR --
IT REALLY SHOULDN'T MATTER WHAT
A RICH PERSON MAKES.
YOU REALLY WANT THE AVERAGE THAT
THE POOR FOLKS MAKE TO BE
INCREASING, AND THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
SO WOULD I HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THE SYRIAN QUESTION SINCE YOU
ARE ONE OF THE VERY FEW ELECTED
OFFICIALS IN WASHINGTON WHO
APPEARS TO BE AT LEAST
SYMPATHETIC FOR THE PRESIDENT'S
POSITION.
WHY HAS THE RESPONSE BEEN
BIPARTISAN IN OUTRAGE ALMOST
UNIVERSALLY HERE?
>> IT SORT OF ONE OF THOSE
STRANGE COMPROMISES IN
WASHINGTON.
THEY ALL SEEM TO BE IN FAVOR OF
CONTINUED INTERVENTION
EVERYWHERE.
THEY NEVER BELIEVE YOU CAN COME
HOME.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKED
ABOUT COMING HOME FROM
AFGHANISTAN, IT WAS LIKE 19
YEARS AND IT'S PRECIPITOUS TO
COME HOME?
REALLY IT'S APPALLING BUT THERE
SEEMS TO BE ALMOST NO ONE
LOOKING AT THE SITUATION.
I WILL TELL YOU ONE
EXTRAORDINARY THING.
FOR MONTHS HAVE BEEN SAYING THE
BEST CHANCE THE SYRIAN KURDS
HAVE IS ACTUALLY MAKING AN
ALLIANCE WITH ASSAD TO PROTECT
THEM AGAINST THE KURDS.
THAT'S ALREADY HAPPENING.
AS WE SPEAK, THEY ARE BEGINNING
TO HAVE AN ALLIANCE.
THE BEST CHANCE OF HAVING SOME
AUTONOMOUS ZONE IS BEING PART OF
SYRIA AND REASSURING TURKEY THAT
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE MAKING
INVASIONS INTO TURKEY.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED INTO IRAQ.
THEY ARE WITHIN THE GOVERNMENT
OF IRAQ AND THEY HAVE THE A
SURETY THAT THEY AREN'T GOING TO
INVADE INTO TURKEY.
INTERESTINGLY, THERE ARE 1800
TURKISH BUSINESSES IN KURDISTAN,
THE KURDISH AREA OF IRAQ NOW,
THAT ARE ACTUALLY GETTING ALONG
WELL.
THAT COULD HAPPEN IN SYRIA TOO.
WE PREVENTED IT THOUGH BECAUSE
WE ARE SAYING YOU CAN'T TALK TO
ASSAD BUT REALLY, YOU PROBABLY
DO EVENTUALLY HAVE TO TALK TO